what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some insanely sad news today
in the world of DC Henry Cavill is not
going to be returning as Superman after
all James Gunn and Peter Safran were
recently announced the new co-ceos of DC
Studios and when they came in they
started to shake things up a little bit
Unfortunately they came in after Black
Adam and Black Adam Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and Henry Cavill had every
intention on bringing Superman back and
they did he was in the post-credits
scene and it seemed like he was back for
good and Dwayne talked about how much he
fought with the studio to get him to
come back however like I said that was
before James Gunn and Peter Safran took
over now unfortunately today Henry
Cavill has released an official
statement telling us all that he is not
going to be back as Superman here's what
he posted to his Instagram he said I
have just had a meeting with James Gunn
and Peter saffron and it's sad news
everyone I will after all not be
returning as Superman after being told
by the studio to announce my return back
in October prior to their hire this news
isn't the easiest but that's life The
Changing of the Guard is something that
happens I respect that James and Peter
have a universe to build I wish them and
all involved with the newest Universe
the best of luck and the happiest of
Fortunes for those who have been by my
side through the years we can mourn for
a bit but then we must remember Superman
is still around everything he stands for
still exists and the examples he sets
for us are still there my turn to where
the cape has passed but what Superman
stands for never will it's been a fun
ride with you all onwards and upwards
again this is super sad to hear but this
was a very very classy and tasteful
Announcement by Henry Cavill he handled
this perfectly you know it's hard on him
you know it's hard for him to deal with
this but despite how hard it might be
for him he is handling it with such
class also I might add that I kind of
feel stupid now because I met him at the
Avatar Premiere when we were in the
theater and I shook his hand and told
him that I was really happy that he was
back a Superman I feel really bad now
although it sounds like he just had a
meeting with them today so unfortunately
we thought they were going to be keeping
him around James Gunn even talked about
how important Superman was in the DC
Universe and he did talk about how he
praised Henry Cavill as Superman but
unfortunately they are coming into a
universe that needs to be rebuilt and it
kind of sounds like James Gunn is
planning on starting from scratch it
makes you wonder what the future holds
for the rest of these franchises that
are coming out or have recently came out
like Black Adam is The Rock still going
to be Black Adam in the DCU it also
makes you question what we thought we
knew Dwayne The Rock Johnson said that
Black Adam was the first movie in their
phase one he announced that DC was doing
phases now however Dwayne announced that
and that was before James Gunn and Peter
saffron took over and since the rock is
the one who brought Superman back and
claimed that it was back that didn't
mean much because unfortunately the rock
is not in charge and Peter Sab Fran and
James Gunn came in and said Superman is
now gone at least Henry Cavill is
Superman we can expect another Superman
to be in the universe James Gunn has
already expressed that Superman is very
important and in this Henry Cavill even
says that Superman is still around
everything that he stands for still
exists in the examples he sets for us
are still there and he simply states
that his turn to where the Cape is over
so it looks like they'll be bringing in
a new Superman but with the news that
James Gunn is canceling Wonder Woman 3
it makes us wonder if Gal Gadot is done
as Wonder Woman now if he was willing to
let cavil go as Superman he is most
likely willing to let Godot go as Wonder
Woman and it sounds like he might
actually be starting from Ground Zero
when he builds his new DC Universe so as
unfortunate as it is it sounds like
nobody is really safe in the DC Universe
that we know however James Gunn did
tweet a poster for a Blue Beetle so I'm
gonna go ahead didn't say Blue Beetle is
okay I'm also going to assume movies
that don't exist in the main DC Universe
like Joker 2 and the Batman and all of
the Batman spin-offs like the penguin
villain series I'm gonna assume they're
okay as well because they don't directly
affect the universe that James Gunn is
trying to build James Gunn has already
expressed that movies TV shows and
including anything that is going to be
on a streaming service and even video
games are all going to be connected to
one Universe although he did say not all
video games are going to be connected
but James Gunn has a plan unfortunately
that plan does not include Henry Cavill
Superman so this is a very sad day I
really really did love Henry Cavill the
Superman I loved Man of Steel a lot of
people didn't but I did I thought it was
amazing and I really loved him as
Superman he was perfect to me and I'm
sure to a lot of different people as
well so this is sad news but let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below and to keep up with the
latest DC news be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell you can
follow us on Instagram Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf